when we left off in the last video we
showed how this generic amino acid could
be converted to this ketone using PLP
however we hadn't gotten to the point
where we were converting alpha
ketoglutarate into the amine so we're
gonna pick up there
we have PLP in its p.m. P stay as the
amine and we're gonna go ahead and call
this stage four of our reaction
here's p.m. P in the last video this
amine group was colored purple because I
have come from the amino acid but I'm
just gonna start with this all in blue
so we can keep track of this amine group
once again here's our molecule of alpha
ketoglutarate I've abbreviated each of
these carboxylic acids a little
differently sorry about that
we could also put co2 - down here as
well and we're going to need an acidic
enzyme residue in this step because the
amine is going to attack the carbonyl
and we'll need a proton to protonate
that so PNP was deprotonated in the
final step this is in great position to
grab this proton and facilitate the
attack so we're deprotonating here these
electrons can come and attack this
carbonyl and we'll protonate using our
enzyme residue if we look back to our
overall reaction we see our carbonyl is
converting to an amine it'll make sense
at this point to eliminate water so
we'll use a basic enzyme residue to
deprotonate here allowing nitrogen to
form a double bond and on its way out
the o h will grab a proton from the
enzyme let's show the arrow pushing to
form our Emmy
and I just noticed I was so focused on
my arrow pushing I need to show PMP at
biological pH so I'm going to go ahead
and protonate the nitrogen so just add
the protons to all of these steps now
our final stage is going to involve
lysine coming in and attaching at this
carbon atom here kicking off our amino
acid but with the double bond here right
now we can't do that so we're going to
need to Tom our eyes to put the double
bond over here so that we're able to
cleave our group off with our incoming
lysine residue let's call this stage
five a two Talmer ization step a basic
enzyme residue will deprotonate here and
we'll be able to push electrons through
grabbing a proton onto the carbon of
this amine so we'll protonate here push
these electrons to make a new amine and
protonate this double bond so even
though we're drawing this flat on paper
this this is a three dimensional active
site and so there's a cage around this
if you will of amino acid residues and
our carefully positioned acidic residue
is going to be oriented in such a way
that we deliver the proton to make the L
amino acid I've just box these to make
them easier to see and let's introduce
our stage six which will be cleavage of
our newly formed amino acid by our
enzyme bound lysine residue for ease
we're showing the sidechain of lysine
not charged so we have just an NH two
and we're going to use a basic enzyme
residue to remove this proton and
facilitate attack
we'll begin our arrow pushing with this
basic residue
and we can grab the proton off of PLP to
finish our arrow pushing
darn I forgot the color-coding of my
amino acid here I knew this would happen
at some point I'm gonna reintroduce it
in this next step and with the magic of
white out we fixed the color coding here
and now we just need to push these
electrons in from lysine to kick off our
newly formed glutamic acid and we're
going to grab a proton on our way out to
protonate this nitrogen so we'll add an
acidic enzyme residue over here notice
i've reoriented PLP and so this oxygen
is poised to grabbed this proton and
facilitate amine formation
so in this final step we've regenerated
PLP in its original enzyme bound state
so the enzyme is ready to complete
another catalytic cycle transamination a
new amino acid
we've also generated glutamic acid and
this can be deaminated so the amine can
be removed and this will produce ammonia
in some organisms the ammonia can be
directly excreted to the surroundings
however in some higher organisms such as
humans ammonia that's released from this
will need to be converted to urea a less
toxic substance and be excreted from the
body that way KP here if you learn
something give me a thumbs up on the way
out and for more chemistry subscribe to
my channel